so there's a lot going on right now in
both the DC and the Marvel Universe and
that is largely to do with the licensing
Expo that is happening in Vegas right
now we've seen and heard news and
releases from both sides we've seen a
poster for Dark Phoenix
we've seen what Shazam looks like now we
saw Aquaman's new armor and now we've
also found out that Wonder Woman will be
getting new armor and Wonder Woman too
before we get started if you're new to
my channel we are currently doing a
giveaway for a free speaker system so
you can enjoy movies in your home just a
little bit more to enter all you need to
do is subscribe to my channel subscribe
to the stupendous waves channel leave a
like on this video and drop a comment
below with your favorite superhero that
could be from DC Marvel or anything else
just a quick note that Wonder Woman too
is not the official title for the sequel
but there is no title yet so we're gonna
refer to it as Wonder Woman - so at the
licensing Expo Warner Brothers showed
off some brand new concept art for
Wonder Woman - and although there was no
photography allowed people talk Daniel
Ellison was at the Expo and tweeted out
a description of the work on display the
tweet red cheetah was literally a tease
image based on what they want it to look
like hard to explain but probably what
you think for Wonder Woman it's a battle
gear pretty cool couple things here in
this tweet one is they mention cheetah
who is the villain in Wonder Woman -
said to be played by Kristen Wiig second
thing is battle armor battle armor sort
of gives us an idea of what her armor
could possibly look like based on the
comics but with this also comes some
questions like is this battle armor
specifically for fighting cheetah and
also is this armor Amazonian and if it
is Amazonian will Diana return to the
mascara as you can see Wonder Woman has
fought cheetah and a few different
outfits and there are a few different
cheetahs but we're not going to get into
that right now
but they said battle armor and when I
hear battle armor and Wonder Woman
I think of Wonder Woman mythologies and
think of the Golden Eagle armor that she
wears it would be just insanely cool if
at one point in the movie and Wonder
Woman - she wore the Golden Eagle armor
I don't think it's really gonna happen
and I think if it does happen it'll be
like at the very end like the last thing
she wears in like the final battle with
cheetah but it would be super awesome if
she did they could go the route of one
woman all-new and Odyssey series but
that's not really armor it's just sort
of more clothing on Wonder Woman I think
if they want to do like a more modern
approach and have her fit in with like
recent times this is the way they'll go
but I hope it's not how she dresses for
the majority of the movie if they go
this way what I would really really love
to see and what I actually think they're
gonna go with is the Wonder Woman armor
in one room in value of 4 numbers 41
through 48 drawn by David Finch
Jonathan Glapion and Brad Anderson this
I think would be awesome because it is
armored it covers her entire body and
she even fights cheetah in this armor
you can see it in number 47 the cheetah
strikes and to me this just makes the
most sense because it is actual battle
armor but it's not so big like the
golden eagle armor that it kind of takes
away from what she looks like so I hope
they go with some sort of variation of
this armor I will say that they've done
a very good job at sticking true to her
look in the comics compared to the work
in the DC EU so I'm really excited to
see it I really enjoyed Wonder Woman I
really enjoyed her costume in the movie
I think it was done very very well and I
am really excited to see what they can
do in Wonder Woman - both with the
costume and with the story plot and just
everything so what are y'all stats on
this do you think that she'll wear one
of these costumes from the comics do you
think they'll stay true to the comics or
just kind of grab from it and make their
own new costume let me know your
thoughts in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video I would appreciate
you hitting that like button and be sure
to subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Wonder Woman to DC and all
things superhero thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf